O meu nome é Maria Palha
e como a nossa apresentadora já disse,
sou formada em psicologia,
e gradualmente fui-me especializando
em empreendedorismo social
e terapia pela arte.
Esta sou eu.
Tenho vindo a saltitar
por todos estes países,
o que também já foi dito aqui,
a desenhar e implementar
programas de saúde mental
em situações de crise humanitária.
Embora possa parecer dramático
vir fazer uma TED para falar de crise
e sofrimento nos dias que correm,
como diz a minha prima Sofia, é exótico
porque passei por todos estes países,
Zimbabué, Líbia, Síria,
Ucrânia, Sudão do Sul,
Índia, Caxemira, etc.
Então é só exótico.
Optei também por não vos vir falar
destes 50 000 milhões
de deslocados de guerra,
ou dos 220 mil mortos na Síria,
em que 2000 são crianças,
ou dos 350 milhões de pessoas
registadas com depressões
ou mau estar psicológico,
porque estes números dos noticiários
sempre me distanciaram do essencial,
sempre me distanciaram das pessoas.
Mas antes de continuar,
gostava de vos pedir
que ouvissem estes sons.
(Silvo de bombas e explosão)
Podem fechar os olhos.
(Sons de gritos e disparos)
Ok, alguém me consegue dizer
o que é que sentiu, numa só palavra?
Terror, boa.
Mais alguém? Não sejam tímidos.
Como?
Desespero.
Medo.
Como?
Revolta.
Mais alguém? São muito tímidos,
Sei que os homens não choram
e as mulheres não trepam às árvores...
(Risos)
Vá lá. O que é que sentiram?
Tristeza.
Angústia.
Horror.
Alguém ficou extremamente feliz?
Se houver alguém, podemos combinar
uma consulta de apoio psicológico aqui.
(Risos)
Alguém ficou apaixonado?
Não.
Pois bem, é exatamente disso
que eu vos venho falar hoje:
de emoções.
Porque é exatamente esta característica
que nos distingue enquanto seres humanos
e nos permite ser resilientes, adaptáveis
e até sobreviver às condições
mais desumanas
que podemos encontrar pela frente.
Mas como não gosto de Excels,
ou seja, não gosto de números,
gosto sim, de pessoas,
escolhi apresentar-vos
três pessoas fantásticas
que conheci ao longo do meu percurso
e que, no fundo, ajudaram
a avalizar esta minha intervenção
e o meu mais recente trabalho
que vos apresento mais à frente.
As fotografias que vos apresento
não são das próprias pessoas
mas representam um bocadinho os ambientes
onde estas pessoas se encontravam.
Esta é uma das primeiras.
Esta fotografia relembra-me o momento
em que eu conheci o Ahmed.
O Ahmed era um líder
de um grupo armado,
e eu conheci-o por telefone.
Ele ligou-me nervoso uma manhã, dizendo:
"Exijo falar contigo porque
sou um líder de um grupo armado".
Não sei se vocês já passaram
por este tipo de convites...
(Risos)
mas quando isto acontece claramente...
Eu aprimorei a minha burca,
estava no Médio Oriente
e apressei-me a encontrar-me com ele.
Encontrou-me na manhã seguinte,
tinha acabado de chegar da linha da frente
e recebeu-me, deu-me um chá
enquanto limpava as armas
que trazia da linha da frente.
Nesse momento ele disse-me:
"Eu estou muito zangado contigo.
"Desde que chegaste à região
toda a gente fala de ti,
"e o pior não é isso,
o pior é que me falam de medo.
"As pessoas vêm-me falar
de paixões separadas pela guerra.
"Sabes o que é isso?
"Paixões separadas pela guerra?
"Vêm-me falar também de esperanças,
angústias, desta questão da família,
"e isso é incomodativo, tenho as pessoas
do meu grupo a falarem sobre isto.
"O pior, não é bem isso
o que me irrita.
"O que me deixa mesmo zangado,
"é o facto de eu próprio
dar por mim a chorar,
"quando equaciono
o facto de enviar o meu filho
"de apenas 12 anos para a linha da frente,
"para levantar os corpos
que estão nos escombros.
"Será que eu estou a enlouquecer?
"Como é que eu vou conseguir
abraçar a minha guerra,
"se eu continuar a ter estas emoções?"
E foi aí que nós explorámos
o que era isto, o abecedário emocional.
Chá após chá,
explorámos o que era esta questão
da regulação das emoções
de modo que não impedissem
a nossa própria performance.
O Rashid foi outra pessoa extremamente
interessante que eu conheci.
E eu conheci-o enquanto
dava uma sessão de grupo.
Nas sessões de grupo
neste tipo de contextos,
as pessoas vêm
com alguns tipos de sofrimento.
E foi curioso porque o Rashid
começou a sessão por me dizer:
"Olha, eu estou felicíssimo.
Acabo de chegar da linha da frente
"e realizei um dos meus sonhos
da minha vida.
"Fui pai de uma criança linda.
"A Mariam tem 6 meses e foi isto
que eu sempre desejei na vida.
"Mas, neste momento, eu gostava
de te pedir para usar um dos benefícios,
"um dos privilégios que eu tinha
e que acabei por perder na guerra:
"O direito à privacidade.
"Por isso, gostava de falar
contigo a sós".
Eu acedi, claro e quando nos encontrámos
numa sessão individual,
ele desabafou, chorando, que se sentia
extremamente culpado
porque não estava a conseguir cumprir
o que havia prometido à sua mulher,
dez anos antes, quando se casaram.
Ele prometera que dormiria abraçado
a ela até ao resto das suas vidas.
E, neste momento, como tinha
sido baleado num braço,
não conseguia dormir abraçado a ela
porque tinha imensas dores
e sentia-se extremamente
culpado e frustrado
com a incapacidade de conseguir
cumprir este desejo que lhe prometera.
Foi aí que juntos explorámos
diferentes formas de expressão de afeto,
diferentes formas de provar o amor,
e de demonstrações de amor.
A Amina, eu conheci-a em Sirte,
numa das cidades líbias,
uma semana antes de Khadafi
ter sido apanhado e morto,
junto aos esgotos do hospital
que nós visitávamos.
Foi uma visita intensa,
nós estávamos no meio da linha da frente,
e o hospital tinha sido sequestrado.
Basicamente, não tinham acesso
a água, nem a saneamento,
ou até a medicamentos
e a equipa cirúrgica não funcionava.
Por isso, toda a população
que estava dentro do hospital
estava naquele momento
sem acesso aos serviços de saúde.
Eu cheguei como psicóloga
— na equipa médica
cada um tem a sua função —
e como psicóloga, cabe-me a mim
fazer o levantamento das necessidades,
identificar quais são os sintomas
que as pessoas podem estar a sentir,
e efetivamente fazer
os primeiros socorros psicológicos.
Naquele momento, eu comecei
a fazer o que tinha que fazer.
Os bombardeamentos
eram extremamente fortes,
por isso, sempre que havia
um bombardeamento, o edifício estremecia.
A determinada altura, percebo
que estou a ser escoltada,
não era por nenhum grupo armado,
era pela Amina,
uma menina de 7 anos que me diz:
"Tu neste momento não podes continuar
sem vir conhecer a minha mãe.
"Faço questão que venhas
conhecer a minha mãe".
E levou-me até à maca da mãe dela.
Quando cheguei e me apresentei,
a Amina não me deixou terminar e disse:
"Então, fantástico,
se estás aqui para ajudar,
"vais ter que me ajudar a vir até
ao sítio onde as bombas estão a rebentar,
"porque é exatamente aí que os meus irmãos
de 3 e 5 anos ficaram
"quando eu e a minha mãe tivemos que fugir
"e porque ela estava ferida
não conseguimos trazê-los ao colo.
"Sozinha, sou pequenina,
não consigo ir buscá-los,
"mas contigo, sendo duas,
conseguimos trazê-los.
" Ajudas-me?"
Foi aí que explorámos esta questão
da importância que têm
os outros na nossa vida.
Questões relacionadas
com medo, com ansiedades,
e conseguimos de certa forma
conter ali aquela situação.
O que todas estas pessoas têm em comum,
e as razões pelas quais eu as trouxe
é o facto de não ser a situação
adversa em que se encontram
que as impossibilita
de dar a volta ao texto.
Todas elas estão
preocupadas com os outros,
e com a sua relação com os outros
e acima de tudo,
tiveram a capacidade de conseguir regular
as emoções que surgiam durante a situação.
Tudo isto porque tiveram
apoio no momento certo.
Foram também estas pessoas
que me levaram a desenvolver
o meu mais recente trabalho
e a acreditar verdadeiramente
que todos nós, se tivermos
um "kit SOS" das emoções
— o nome até é "sexy" —
conseguiríamos, de certa forma ,
promover mais bem-estar
não só em nós como
nas pessoas que nos rodeiam.
Basicamente os estudos indicam
que uma das maiores causas de depressão
ou de mal-estar psicológico é a sensação
de que nós não temos amigos verdadeiros.
Esta é uma das frases mais comuns.
Por isso, eu acredito que,
se cada um de nós conseguir
construir o seu próprio "kit" de emoções
esse "SOS" das emoções,
conseguirá criar, de certa forma,
uma conta poupança de emoções prazerosas
que podem ser acionadas
quando estamos confrontados
com situações de crise ou adversas
na nossa vida.
Neste "kit" o que é importante
é que cada um consiga reconhecer,
identificar e monitorizar
quando nos sentimos bem
e quando nos sentimos mal.
Quantas vezes se passam 6 meses
sem sabermos o que estamos a sentir
e demoramos a dar uma resposta
— pequenos "delays" (atrasos).
Havendo esta monitorização, conseguiremos
dar uma resposta mais rápida.
Neste "kit", é importante também
aprender a identificar sinais de alerta.
Muitas vezes, atingimos o nosso limite
e não conseguimos estancar ali a situação
porque não conhecemos
os nossos próprios sinais de alerta.
É importante conhecê-los.
Neste "kit", e acima de tudo,
é identificar "band-aids" emocionais
— também é "sexy", o nome —
e, basicamente, este "Band-Aid" é para
as vezes que temos situações adversas
ou mazelas emocionais:
a mãe deixou de falar,
o namorado terminou,
houve um divórcio, uma morte.
Isto é uma mazela emocional.
Se nós tivermos um "Band-Aid"
que já temos dentro de nós,
— às vezes só não o reconhecemos —
para podermos estancar
esta ferida emocional,
conseguiremos, de certa forma,
dar uma volta mais eficaz à situação.
E, acima de tudo, esta questão
das fontes de bem-estar.
Uma vez que esta história
da felicidade e da harmonia
vem sempre como um produto final,
e raramente lhe damos importância
no dia a dia, no hoje, no aqui, no agora.
O facto de conseguirmos
identificar fontes de bem-estar
para o nosso dia a dia,
permitir-nos-á viver hoje, aqui, agora,
duma forma bastante mais prazerosa.
Tudo isto, se tivermos mais bem-estar,
seremos, como dizem os estudos,
mais criativos,
mais produtivos, mais resilientes,
e acima de tudo, conseguiremos ter
melhores relações com os outros,
abraçar o que eu acredito ser
a nossa responsabilidade universal
de promover o nosso bem-estar
e dos que nos rodeiam,
contribuindo assim
para sociedades mais harmoniosas,
menos agressivas, mais empáticas
e acima de tudo, mais humanas,
não só para nós
como para as gerações futuras,
os nossos filhos que aí vêm.
(Aplausos)